débattre ici aujourd'hui de ceux qui détruisent l'
avenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu ce que faisait le curcuma kurta
en Suède, j'ai pensé que c'était tellement inspirant que
nous devrions savoir que cela devient plus grand pour que
vous me connaissiez Kira et moi, nous avons commencé, nous avons
posté un  vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux et elle
est devenue virale, puis nous avons fait notre première
grève et nous étions là avec 3000 donc
c'était incroyable Je pense que j'appartiens à une
génération mondiale qui se concentre sur le
changement climatique Je pense que ce sera le problème de
notre génération et que  nous devrons tous
faire face il s'agit de notre avenir
les
jeux politiques nous venons de vous savez que nous pouvons
regarder le système d'un
point de vue plus éloigné Je n'ai pas vraiment
confiance dans le système politique Je
pense que le système est vraiment mauvais parce que
quand nous parlons aux politiciens ils disent
ouais nous voulons faire ça  et ceci et
cela mais nous  peut à cause de ceci et ceci
et cela et donc je pense que si ce système
vous empêche de prendre vraiment bien
soin de cette planète, c'est un mauvais système,
alors changez le système, ne vous contentez pas de fermer
les yeux et de le prendre comme si ce n'était pas
nous ne devons rien à personne, nous vous tenons
responsables des problèmes qui sont
ici maintenant et nous pouvons simplement vous dire que
parce que c'est notre avenir,
je veux vraiment dire aux jeunes d'aujourd'hui
qu'il est si important que nous nous battions tous
pour avoir un meilleur climat  politique selon laquelle nous
devons tous travailler ensemble, nous avons vraiment besoin
de nous connecter les uns aux autres et de
surveiller les partis politiques et juste vous
savez que nous sommes tous sur le globe de ce monde sur
cette terre ensemble, donc nous devons vraiment
travailler ensemble pour essayer de réparer  nos maisons
parce que notre maison est en feu donc nous avons vraiment
besoin d'avoir de l'eau et d'
éteindre un feu et nous devons le faire ensemble
maintenant